The American fitness industry is worth over 30 billion dollars a year.
That's a lot of fancy gear and gym memberships.
But Memo doesn't believe in gadgets.
This is Memo's heart monitor.
This is Memo's gym.
This is Memo's nutrition plan.
And this is Memo's locker.
Memo doesn't believe in swanky gyms or boutiquey yoga studios.
He doesn't believe in self-promotion even though there would be a lot to promote.
You know what Memo really believes in?
Memo believes in running.
On November 3rd, Memo will take a day off to run the New York City Marathon.
He's on track to run faster than ever.
Memo reminds us that we're being sold and packaged something that's free.
Achievement doesn't come from a sports brand or the latest hi-tech gizmo.
Just ask Memo.
He believes in just three...
Two!
Right.
Two things.
That's the Memo method.